forget serving our country by signing up
for the military
radical democrats like aoc want you to
join
the civilian court of battle climate
change
the plan cost 10 billion dollars
and would have the government hire 1.5
million americans to quote
transition to a clean economy
all right i'll start with you uh jesse
how do we transition
to a clean economy
yeah with aoc's ground troops she's
trying to buy a movement with my money
what 1.5 million mini aocs on the
federal payroll
that's our tax dollars maga didn't start
like that hope and change didn't start
like that you can't just
buy a base with with tax dollars that's
not how it works
and it's not like they're going to go
around and lower the earth's temperature
or sea levels
they're not even going to pick up litter
they don't have the technical expertise
to build a solar panel
so what are they actually doing they're
going to be campaigning for democrats in
the midterms
they're going to be bullying people and
then when aoc decides to run for
president
click she's got 1.5 little supporters in
her back pocket
i get what she's doing you know shannon
the jesse is right it's all the money
for this the 10 billion dollars is going
to come from
increased taxes tax hikes and
the the question is what exactly
not only are they going to do but the
money that's being
paid for these people is also they're
getting health care
they're getting child care they're
getting 25 000
if they've got any educational debt 50
for more education if they need it what
what is this really about
well judge uh you're right about the
taxes that's been discussion let's move
the u.s corporate
tax rate up several percentage points
but there are a number of democrats who
said
please do not do that that's actually
going to hurt us on the global stage
they think this kind of stuff is
actually going to make us
less competitive my worry is yeah i
don't know exactly what they're going to
do one of the things
was talked about taking care of parks
and public lands which i i think we
already have people who do that i don't
know
exactly what they're going to do i just
know i don't want them showing up and
giving me a ticket for having my third
red meat meal of the week like my third
cheeseburger bacon cheeseburger
i don't want to be getting ticketed for
that out in public um but we have to
think about what they're going to do
listen if there's some way to quantify
to show that this is actually
bettering the environment in some way it
is actually
a good cost benefit analysis okay maybe
if there are metrics for us to track it
but otherwise i think a lot of folks are
going to be skeptical because the last
time we were sold this
there are going to be green jobs and
shovel-ready jobs
out there for folks and and there's work
to be done people are going to be a
little skeptical based on the way it
played out the last time we were told
that
well and you know lawrence one of the
things she is uh promoting is she says
that we're going to take flint and
baltimore and the south bronx and
and or no st louis uh whose
infrastructure was not properly built in
the first place
and the climate warriors are going to
rectify that and they're going to get
everything they need for
uh social justice what does that mean to
you you know as much as i disagree
with her and her strategy she's pretty
smart
this is what the left does think about
acorn remember all that money that we
pumped into there it was just a democrat
group
look at the obamacare navigators program
they were supposed to sign people up for
obamacare but they were secretly storing
that data for politics this is all
politics
she knows that she can hire these young
people as ground troops and guess what
else she gets
she gets to pay off their their college
in the process
of doing this this is how you cancel the
debt so
you know as much as i disagree with her
i see what she's doing and the
republicans
better get their act together and come
up with a plan to counter this because
let me tell you something you already
lost to college campuses
you're getting ready to lose secondary
education elementary school
definitely a loss look what they're
already teaching the kids right there
today
conservatives have to counter this
message with a conservative
ground game not paid by the government
but by the private sector
well uh juan what what do you say you'd
think this is a beneficial program with
all of these
uh you know pretty much uh entitlements
uh
attached to it i mean they can get 75
000 just for education if they join this
workforce well i think we do that for
people going into the military obviously
we've had
you know uh gi bill that help people out
i'm just listening because
to me i think back historically we've
had
in this country we still have a peace
corps we have a
an americorps to help teachers uh
we've had under fdr a civilian
conservation corps
and that was a great success you know
and it was a jobs program
as well i don't know that it you know
somehow was a political program but yes
people definitely have a positive
feeling about
how fdr got us out of the great
depression
if that's your point i understand it but
i i'm just listening because to me
she's young she's idealistic and i don't
think those are bad things those are
very
american characteristics and if she sees
a way for young people to get
job training to get jobs to pay for
education billion dollars
one ten billion it's not real it's not
legislation people
it's an idea judge it's not real yet
it's
oh well you know who to thunk that we'd
be adding another six
uh trillion dollars to the budget anyway
uh six billion the fastest hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else